PERCENTAGE.
PHILIPP GRUBAUOUT
THERE.
HE CAN ABSOLUTELY CRUSH YOU.
6'7" . THATTHE LIGHTNING BLUE O
,  BLUE LINING, CAN'T GIVE
THOSE UP.
THE ONE THING IT HAS BEEN
MISSING IS GOALSCORING. UARD BE
LIGHTNING JERSEY.
THAT
ALEX KILLORN WHIPS IT NE.
I LIKE THE WAY THE LIGHTNING
HAVE DONE AT THE LAST HANDFUL
OF GAMES
BRANDON TANEV, FINDS A LELE
THE FIRST PERIOD FOR THE
LIGHTNING.
CALL PERRY,  PICKED UP AN
ASSISTST
HEDMAN GOES UP THE ICE TO
KILLORN.
KILL
PUT BACK OUTSIDE THE LINE AND
SENT BACK IN BY KILLORN.N. L
FOOTE.
THE PUCK GOES INTO THE CORNER,
INSIDE THE LIGHTNING BLUE YEAR
SCHWARTZ WITH A GREAT YEAR INAN
VASILEVSKIY HAS THAT.
NET, PLA
THE POINT,
EARLY ON, HE WAS MAYBE MEDIOCRE
>> Brian: THAT WAS McDONAGH
COMING ACROSS.
HE
BACKUP BY SEATTLE BACK INSIDE
THE LINE.
WE ARE NEARING THE END OF THE
PERIOD THTHNG HAS BEEN AT ARMS
PIERRE-EDOUARD BELLEMARE , WHO
HAS BEEN UP AND DOWN IN THAT
DEPARTMENT, EARLY ON IN KNESS,
THE PUCK, GOING LOW RELLI UP AH
AND JUST INSIDE THE LINE. TOUGH
THAT WHEN HE GETS GOING, HE WAS
BOARDS.
MOVES DOWN LOW, A OT, IT WASAS
IN THE COMMISSION SAID, THEY
ONLY HAD FIVE SHOTS IN THE
SECOND  PERIOD BUT THEY HAVE
REALLY CONTROFLEURY NINE.
THE SHOT FROM COREY PERRY JUST
GOES WIDE.
ACROSS TO CAL FOOTE.  SITUATION
PIERRE-EDOUARD BELLEMARE
STEPPING OUT OF THE BOX.
WITH THE POWER PLAY, 50 SECONDS
REMAINING IN IT.  PALAT.
IT WAS
>> Dave: VICTOR HEDMAN BACK OUT
THERE